foreign
[Music]
we are looking as far back as currently
humanly possible and that is our goal is
to keep trying to study further and
further back so that we can understand
better the time in Cosmic history that
we've only been able to really theorize
[Music]
when I saw the first image of Neptune
with James Webb Space Telescope I
actually started to cry I had been
waiting for over 30 years to see this
planet again like that what I saw first
and foremost was the ring system of
Neptune to see the ring system in all of
its Glory with the first jwst image of
Neptune I was just blown away
foreign
[Music]
kind of our first chance at studying
another star system that has a bunch of
small rocky planets to say okay how
different are they what does that mean
about their potential for supporting
life
[Music]
[Applause]